I do Transcendental Meditation
um and when I and there are different
that's a mantra based vegetation so
anyway here's how it works and there are
met different Mantra based presentations
but the process is a real simple process
there's a
um it's called the Mantra which is a
word that has no meaning that really
almost becomes a sound that you repeat
in your head while quietly uh what with
your eyes closed and in a comfortable
position and it might be something like
oh
you know you breathe on in and out and
so on and when your mind is focused on
that it can't have thoughts because it's
focused on that and so it takes your
what your mind is like a monkey jumping
all over the place and you can't control
it you know you you say I'm uh I'll sit
there and I won't thing well you'll
think and it'll jump all over the place
so the main thing that this Mantra does
is it focuses your attention on that and
it gets you away from thinking and then
eventually the Mantra sort of Fades in
the background goes over and over and
over and it fades in the background and
then you go into a subliminal State
um which means
um and it's not a black and white thing
there are various degrees of depth to
this uh but anyway it goes into the
subliminal state which
um is is not like being awake or asleep
it's kind of like being very quiet and
not conscious because that's really
taking you into your subconscious so it
takes you into your subconscious
um and
um in your subconscious it's peace and
and so on and and Tranquility it's also
like the subconscious is where
creativity comes from it's like if you
wanna so it's a um if you want to be
creative you don't muscle it you in your
conscious mind pretty much you go take a
hot shower you relax and greater ideas
come to you